let's talk about fruit fruit is one of
the most perfect human foods
take for instance about how a piece of
fruit looks
tastes and smells to us in its natural
state it's absolutely beautiful and
enticing and appetizing to us for us to
see a video or a picture or even be in
person of picking
fresh ripe beautifully colored fruit off
of a tree
or a vine now compare that to
dismembering an animal
there is nothing appetizing to us about
the skinning and dismemberment of an
animal
and blood dripping from their body
fruits taste
absolutely delicious to us and we love
to see
videos of people picking fresh fruit we
even take children to go strawberry
picking
and make it a field trip but we
definitely don't take kids to a trip to
the slaughterhouse
hey guys welcome to the ellen fisher
podcast today we're going to be talking
about
simplifying plant-based nutrition and
tips to thrive that i personally
have found helpful in my journey we're
going to be breaking this up into two
parts because there's a lot of
information i want to cover
but today for part one i want to talk
specifically
about simply what's natural for us to
help make sense and break apart the
noise in diet culture
i'm going to talk about my health
journey and also tips to thrive and if
you'd like to get even more tips than i
share in this episode today you can get
any of my ebooks at ellenfischer.com
filled with beginner vegan tips health
tips and encouragement
all of our family's favorite recipes
that are both delicious and nourishing
tips for raising healthy plant-based
kids and more so who am i addressing in
this episode
those who are looking for answers to
feel your best but you're confused by
all the conflicting information
those of you who are into plant-based
eating or want to start eating
plant-based and dip your toes in it
and also maybe even some of you who have
tried eating vegan or plant-based in the
past
but stopped for a variety of reasons
including possibly just
missing the mark on filling your best
and hitting those health markers that
are so important to thrive because
it can be really easy to get confused so
many people go through life just very
confused on what to eat or how to live
in a way that's going to help them feel
their best
to not only have great fertility and
healthy mindset about food that also
helps them to eat until they're
satisfied while maintaining
optimal weight hormone balance and
having great digestion
and good sustained energy while also
eating in a way that promotes longevity
and preventing disease
so i think it's helpful to look at all
of this and this whole topic with a
balance
of taking the science into consideration
and also taking logic into consideration
and just
meshing both of them together and i feel
like i've learned a lot along the way so
first i want to share with you
my personal healing journey i have been
vegan for
over actually almost 15 years now and
i am so thankful for my health i'm
thankful for having wonderful digestion
i have had four wonderfully healthy
being in pregnancies
vegan pregnancies and i'm raising four
incredibly healthy children
and my partner is plant-based as well
but i wasn't always feeling great my
whole life
i went from when i was younger being
able to eat anything that i wanted
and having zero consequences to once i
hit puberty experiencing acne poor
digestion
um not feeling just my best overall and
weight gain as well
and i was just really confused on what
to do i had very little
understanding on how to be healthy the
way that my diet consisted of was
literally
hot cheetos and snicker bars from the
vending machine that i would share with
my friend in between classes
and after school i would get taco bell
gorditas
and definitely experienced a ton of
processed foods within my diet but i
also ate a lot of vegetables my mom made
home-cooked meals every day for dinner
and breakfast and with that came a lot
of meat cheese milk and eggs so within a
couple years of
weight gain and experiencing acne that i
just could not figure out how to get rid
of
i began restricting my calories and
because i really didn't understand
nutrition
and how to eat for a healthy body like i
said i thought restricting my calories
was the answer to all my problems that i
would lose weight and go back to the
weight that i was before where i could
just eat whatever i wanted
and that hopefully my acne would
disappear and little by little i started
eating
less and less calories i got down to a
point where i was eating 10 almonds for
dinner i would like hide out
i was i had a job at the time and in on
my break i would hide out in the corner
and eat just like 10 almonds
i would have like a yogurt for breakfast
and very very little food
but the problem with that is that i
would restrict restrict and then binge i
mean there's so many problems with
restricting your calories which we'll
get into
but the binging part was the most
interesting thing because because
i limited the amount of food i was in
taking i was also taking in less
nutrition less nutrients in my body so
therefore when you don't eat enough food
in general and then you end up
being around these super dense
calorically rich foods
you're going to gravitate towards those
and binge because your body
needs calories your body needs food and
nutrition so i would go
binge or restricting restricting and
then binging
and it came to a point after a couple of
years i was around 19
years old where i learned about the raw
food diet and at the time i really had
no idea what a whole foods plant-based
diet was or even veganism
but something clicked within me that day
where i realized that i needed to eat
for a healthy body inside and out and
not to eat for an unhealthily skinny
body because when i was restricting i
had gotten down to 109 pounds
or 106 pounds which is very very low for
me i lost about 25 pounds
and i was so sick and unhealthy
definitely not thriving at all
and not even to mention physical changes
within my body my mental state was not
well i was constantly thinking about
food and i was just overall
just very unhappy so how i healed after
that was i began
reading all the health books i could get
my hands on i was working at this
grocery store called mother's market at
the time in california and every time
was my break i would just grab all the
health books and start reading them
and looking into everything i could find
about eating
fresh fruits and vegetables and i
naturally began eating a lot more fruits
and vegetables i stopped restricting my
calories
i actually got a kitchenette to put in
my college dorm with one of those
nutribullet blenders i had a mini fridge
and i definitely was the oddball
in college that most girls most people
were not doing that
in our college and i did not care i was
just so happy that i was able to start
eating again
and i felt so much better in my mental
state
number one but also within my body i
began gaining weight
which was inevitable i had completely
destroyed my metabolism
and it definitely took some time to heal
my body gained weight but eventually
leveled out to like my optimal weight
and i just trusted my body
i realized like i had said something
clicked within me and i needed to eat
for my health i remember in college one
day eating like a big bowl of plums and
i just suddenly felt this food freedom
that i could just eat
fresh fruits and vegetables in abundance
and focus on my health inside
and the outward will respond when you're
healthy on the inside i began to feel
energy good digestion my acne started
clearing up and
i got my period back because i had lost
my period for a period of time
from eating so few calories on my
journey i learned about the science of
whole foods plant-based eating and even
further fine tweaked my diet to be
eating
nourishing and nutrient dense plant
foods and while in the beginning i
started out
eating this way for my health i
eventually was suggested a video
called the best speech you'll ever hear
by gary yourofsky
and that video completely flipped my
worldview upside down and i became an
ethical vegan
overnight and it just so happens that
the foods that are healthy
healthiest for us also are kinder to the
animals
and are have a lighter footprint on the
planet as well and
i just really felt so good i knew that i
was on the right path and
it's i've never looked back so it's been
almost 15 years now i've learned a lot
along the way
and i'm just so thankful for amazing
digestion
and good fertility having a good mental
state with my food
with food that i'm eating that i'm not
constantly thinking about food
and i can experience optimal weight by
eating until i'm totally satisfied
all right so a few of my favorite
plant-based books i love the book whole
rethinking the science of nutrition
by nutritional biochemist t colin
campbell he
really makes it clear and easy to
understand why so much science is skewed
because they're looking at in a
reductionist way they're looking at
research in a reductionist way instead
of
looking at the whole picture so i love
that book i highly recommend it
and then i also love the book fiber
fueled by will bolsoewitz md
and he that book is just amazing he
talks a lot about gut health and how the
number one
most important factor for gut health is
diversity of plants
there's also a new book coming out by my
friend simon hill and i cannot wait to
read it it's called the proof is in the
plants
so highly recommend that if you know
australia i'm pretty sure that one is
already out in australia
there's honestly so many amazing books
these are just a few of my favorites
first i think it's really important to
look at the evidence
a whole foods plant-based diet is the
only diet clinically proven to not only
stop but reverse heart disease america's
number one killer
which is huge and definitely needs to be
taken into consideration when we're
talking about our optimal diet
the academy of nutrition and dietetics
the world's largest organization of food
and nutritional professionals agrees
that a well-planned vegan diet is not
only nutritionally adequate but also may
be helpful in the prevention
and treatment of diseases the most
reliable evidence we can go off of
is well-constructed large observational
studies with people all across the world
as well as randomized clinical trials
and vegans and vegetarians have
less risk of heart disease and cancers
in almost all studies across the board
we know from the scientific body of
evidence that saturated fat causes heart
disease
so increased meat consumption taking you
out of that plant predominant diet
includes increases your risk of
cardiovascular
disease dementia and some cancers and
when i say
predominant plant-based diet i'm talking
where more than 80
of your calories are coming from plants
at least meat is nutrient dense it is
but it comes at a cost
of gaining and accessing many calories
from those foods in the long run and
long term
i think a great way to look at this
topic is to look at the five areas of
the blue zones
these are the civilizations that had the
longest living civilizations and the
most centurions
in the world and they all had shared
nine characteristics
including but not limited to a
predominantly plant-based diet the
majority of blue zones consume only
small amounts of meat on rare occasions
and all of them
eat a wide and rich array of fresh
fruits and vegetables which are packed
with disease-fighting nutrients
the okinawans in particular one of the
five blue zone areas
ate only three percent of their calories
from animal products
and in fact in the blue zone study one
of the healthiest subgroups within that
study
were the vegans in the seventh-day
adventist group in loma linda california
the okinawans who ate traditionally a
predominant plant-based diet we're also
one of the longest living with only
three percent of their calories from
animal foods
have since changed their traditional
diet and as a result their
longevity and their health has decreased
over time there are some people that
want to try to debunk the blue zone
study but
okay can you name me one long living
civilization culture who ate an
ancestral diet who ate a meat heavy or
predominant heavy of animal foods or
even just a lot of animal foods in their
diet and have a long life expectancy
it is just not out there all right we
can talk about the science all day long
but i hope that in the future we can
have
some wonderful conversations with
plant-based nutritionists and doctors
and experts here on the show
i really plan on having that happen and
it's going to be so fun and i can't wait
but for now i want to move on to how
plant-based nutrition does not have to
be super complicated
there is so much food freedom when you
understand how the body works what
naturally is good for you and what
different foods
do and how they function in the body and
what foods promote health and longevity
because there are a hundred different
ways to eat a vegan diet
and not all or even most of them are
healthy there's going to be slight
variations within
different people who are thriving of
course it's not like going to be 100
bulletproof for every single detail
but overall not all of them are going to
be healthy for sure
so let me just say this up front just
because something says it's vegan
doesn't mean it's healthy now that
doesn't mean you should never eat that
food i think balance is so important
but if we're talking from a nutritional
standpoint and what's going to help us
thrive
it's super important to say up front
that just because something says it's
vegan
does not make it healthy you can
definitely eat a very unhealthy vegan
diet
just like you can eat a very unhealthy
diet that has animal foods in it
all right so let's break it down and
talk about our natural diet and
something very simple to understand
within different foods let's talk about
fruit fruit is one of the most perfect
human foods
take for instance about how a piece of
fruit looks
tastes and smells to us in its natural
state it's absolutely beautiful and
enticing and appetizing to us for us to
see a video or a picture even be in
person of picking
fresh ripe beautifully colored fruit off
of a tree
or a vine even brightly colored greens
and vegetables in a garden appeal to us
by sight
taste and smell there is joy in picking
brightly colored fruits and vegetables
in nutrient-dense soil and we find the
process beautiful with not only fruits
but vegetables as well
now compare that to dismembering an
animal there is
nothing appetizing to us about the
skinning and dismemberment of an animal
and blood dripping from their body
there's a reason that social media
influencers who
promote eating animal products is
healthy are not showing the
dismemberment
and skinning of animals i'm not to talk
i'm not talking about like
hunter pages you know that are
completely about hunting i'm talking
specifically diet pages that are about
what's healthy for you they're not going
to be showing videos of animals being
dismembered
on their page because we all know nobody
wants to see that there's nothing
beautiful to it to us about it in
comparison
when it comes to showing something like
fresh ripe fruit
that should tell us a lot by what
naturally looks good to us
in its natural state especially a
well-grown
ripe fruit tree the fruits taste
absolutely delicious to us and we love
to see
videos of people picking fresh fruit we
even take children to grow strawberry
picking
and make it a field trip but we
definitely don't take kids to a trip to
the slaughterhouse
that should say a lot it's very
important for us to realize that
slaughterhouses do not have glass walls
for a reason we do not want to see it
it's not appetizing to us it isn't until
we douse it with plant foods spices
herbs
and cook it in oil that animal foods
began to be
appetizing to us so now let's go to
another one let's talk about
dairy dairy is one of the most obvious
non-human foods
dairy is a perfect food for a baby calf
it's wonderful food
for a baby cow because just like my
human milk and
your human milk is made specifically for
your baby
cow's milk is specifically designed for
baby calves just like
monkey milk is for baby monkeys giraffe
milk is for baby giraffes
and so on there's a reason why you don't
see other animals
eating milk from another species
especially after they've weaned off of
their mothers we are the only species
that enjoys milk
after we've weaned off of our mothers
especially what's interesting is that
it's not even from our own species milk
it's from another animal
each mammal's milk is specifically and
nutritionally designed
for their young and i think it's really
important to look at
how a lot of people will say well our
ancestors ate milk and that must mean
that it's good for us
but it's important to note and to
realize that just because we ate
something in our past does not mean it's
nutritionally
adequate or good for us when we were
traveling across the world
uh making civilizations into different
areas
and places that we didn't know if there
would be food and easy access
to foods to sustain us having cow's milk
and
using animals to domesticate them
and to ensure a significant significant
calorie source
makes complete sense and that does not
mean that it was made
well that's what we should be eating to
thrive it's what they ate to survive
there's a huge difference there
surviving and thriving
and that's one of the most important
factors to consider so when you take a
step back and you realize our biology
and you realize that
cows don't make milk just to make milk
they specifically make milk for their
young
that brings a whole new understanding
and just simple picture of whether we
are designed to be eating cow's milk
we as humans do not need milk once we
are weaned off of our mothers
breast milk is specifically designed for
our babies and as they get older
and grow out of the need for that we do
not need milk from
our own mothers or any other mammal ever
again
some meat enthusiasts when making the
argument that we are supposed to be
eating
a lot more animal foods and not very
many plants is they compare us to cows
saying that cows have four stomachs and
they are grass eaters therefore we're
not supposed to be eating very many
plants or
leafy greens but of course we are not
grass eaters
it's very clear we don't have four
stomachs and it's not a fair comparison
we are actually more consistent and in
line to our design to that of a
frugivore to an ape or bonobo monkey who
eats
largely consisting of fresh fruits and
also leafy greens with very little meat
they eat meat more opportunistically
and there's some usage and importance in
using the word opportunistic omnivore
where we as a species have the ability
to eat and survive on both plant and
animal matter
and being omnivores gives these animals
the opportunity to have food security in
times of stress
or uncertainty there's some discussion
we have
about the label for us as humans and
whether we're omnivores or opportunistic
omnivores or frugivores or herbivores or
starchivores
or starchivorus omnivores or what is it
frugivorous omnivores
whatever the term we can still take a
step back and realize
what our biology is and look at things
like our intestines and our teeth and
just take a basic understanding
of what we are supposed to be eating to
help us feel our best long term the
length of our intestinal tracts is
similar to that
of a frugivore carnivorous animals have
intestinal
tract lengths that are three to six
times their body trunk
they have nice short intestinal tracts
so that meat can
flow freely through that whereas
herbivores have intestinal tracts that
are 10 to 12
times the body length of their trunk and
humans have the same
exact ratio of intestinal tracts to that
of herbivores
also if we talk about stomach acidity
what is the main
enzyme in our saliva is called amylase
which is a carbohydrate digesting
enzyme which makes it more easily for
your body to break down and absorb
and the interest to your digestive tract
should be a really clear signal
of what we should be eating there are
hundreds of things which make us more
likely to be drawn towards
more plant foods than not for example
fiber is essential for a good digestion
we should be eating lots of fiber and if
you're eating meat or animal foods at
every meal you're at risk of not getting
enough fiber because we need
such a great size of it such a great
amount so clearly we can survive on meat
we can survive on animal foods and our
ancestors in the past did eat them to
survive but there is a big difference
between what will help us thrive long
term
versus merely surviving something else i
find fascinating is how
easy it is to forget the amount of
energy that it goes into to create
animal foods and processed foods as well
without
government subsidies we would have a
much easier time understanding
how much these foods should cost and how
much energy it goes into producing these
foods
specifically animal foods in conjunction
with processed foods
our government subsidizes animal foods
as well as the crops that we use to feed
the animals and
the crops that go into the majority of
processed foods namely corn and soy
if the government didn't subsidize these
things animal foods and processed foods
would cost significantly higher amounts
and we would naturally not be eating
near as much of it there's a reason that
a box of lucky charms
and a cheeseburger from mcdonald's cost
less than just a head of broccoli
think about how many ingredients and how
much production
goes into creating that cheeseburger or
a box of cereal
compared to just eating a head of
broccoli and buying just a broccoli that
was grown in a garden
because our government does not put an
emphasis towards subsidizing
near as much of fresh fruits and
vegetables which is
if we're gonna subsidize anything that's
what we should be subsidizing and as a
result it creates this disproportionate
understanding
of what amounts of foods we should be
eating because it seems so easy
the animal foods are significantly
cheaper than they would be if our
government instead had a goal of health
instead of catering to powerful
lobbyists our tax dollars could go
towards more nutrient and calorically
dense plant foods instead
now the topic of food deserts and food
insecurity is obviously very layered and
this is not really going into it that
much and i would love to eventually
have an expert on the podcast to do a
whole episode on this show for that
and lastly when talking about nature and
what foods are
optimal for us let's talk about how we
naturally teach children
to be kind to animals our inclination is
to tell them to be gentle to the cat be
nice to the dog don't pull on the
kitty's tail
hold the baby duck carefully don't let
them fall and in fact
if an animal if a child is showing
tendencies to hurt animals
we consider that a red flag and
something to be really looking into and
as scary
because children naturally love animals
which should tell us
a lot even looking at something as
simple
as child movies where the animals are
the heroes the animals are the ones that
we love
and the people who are trying to hurt
them kill them
or lock them up in cages are the bad
guys we can look at movies like
dumbo nemo chicken run bambi
free willy the list goes on
children naturally love animals it isn't
until we condition them to teach them
that certain animals are worth
protecting
and other animals are not and we're
supposed to be eating
that they start to change their mind
also i think it's worth mentioning that
some people say they don't feel negative
feelings when they kill or hunt an
animal
then why is it that slaughterhouse
workers have some of the highest rates
of depression and ptsd
regularly researchers have concluded
that it's an ultra hazardous activity
for
psychological well-being understandably
so right
none of you really want to be working in
a slaughterhouse to you so the basic
understanding
of all this really helps to clear the
mud and understand just the basics all
right so let's get into the tips that
help us
thrive this is my personal experience
and one of the things that i really have
found helpful
is to get back to nature purchasing
organic
yes but it's so much more than that the
nutritious
aspect of your soil is super important
and impactful on your health
it's so much more than just an organic
label so purchase
from farmers markets when you can grow
your own food even if you can
just a little bit you can grow sprouts
in your window or even have a few potted
plants outside your door with some fresh
herbs or grains
and purchasing locally is also very
helpful as well
if you're only getting your foods from
big botch grocery stores
your plant foods your vegetables that's
not going to be as ideal
but i realize a lot of you or some of
you may be living in cold climates
for part of the year simply just do the
best you can and take advantage in the
summer time
in the summertime really go for it grow
some watermelon grow the fresh fruits
that are
access accessible to where you live and
go to the farmers markets weekly get as
much local
locally grown food as you can in the
area that you're in
and just like i said do the best you can
also frozen fruits and veg are a great
option for those of you who don't have
access to
many fresh local fruits because frozen
fruits are picked when ripe than flash
frozen as opposed to
fresh fruits that are flown thousands of
miles
apart and often are picked far before
peak ripeness then sometimes they're
even
put under ethylene gas in their cargo
containers to
ripen up and look like they're ready to
eat which is
completely and starkly different from a
locally picked
fresh ripe fruit or vegetable that is
close to the soil
and has these medicinal properties and
opportunities when you have that access
to
pick fresh and ripe from the soil right
from the ground
locally in the garden or at a farmers
market compared to
a fruit or a vegetable that's flown so
far apart and is detached from that
opportunity of those wonderful health
benefits of getting it local
whereas frozen vegetables and fruits are
picked
when they're ripe and frozen within six
to eight hours of picking
so that's an option as well so why is
local better local foods tend to be
picked more ripe and more fresh
you can get to know the farmer if you're
getting it from the farmers markets and
learn about their practices what
fertilizers they use and what nutrients
they're adding back to the soil
smaller local farms tend to put more
care
more often times into their soil and the
way that they're growing their food
so you're more likely to be getting a
more nutritious product a more
nutritious
fruit and vegetable you can also grow
your own food which is obviously going
to be local and then you'll have full
power over the health of the soil
you can add vegetable composting and
worm castings and all those things
really add up
through having a more nutritious meal
with every bite when you're getting more
locally grown foods that you can
the next tip is to eat predominantly
whole foods it's actually very simple
when you break it down what is the
difference between an isolated food
and a whole food whole foods contain all
three macronutrients of carbohydrates
protein and fat
some are going to have more of one
macronutrient than the other but they
all contain all three of them
nonetheless and along with that they
also contain
fiber water all of their antioxidants
and mineral content
as well when you isolate a food you take
away almost everything except that one
component
take olive oil for example which is the
fat from olives
you're basically taking away the water
and the fiber and the other
macronutrients of carbohydrates and
protein
processed sugar is isolated
carbohydrates better instead to eat the
whole fruit that has carbohydrates in it
yes but also the
water and the fiber and all the other
minerals and the other macronutrients as
well by eating these isolated foods you
take away
the way nature's intent designed for us
to eat it
there's a reason there aren't oil bushes
or processed sugar trees out there we
are supposed to be eating foods
that have all of their macronutrients as
well as the
water and fiber content intact and along
with it you get all those added vitamins
antioxidants and minerals
with it so a good way to understand this
is that
one tablespoon of olive oil contains 100
of its calories from fat
which is about 100 calories and your
body signals and tells you
when to stop eating by the amount of
water and fiber content as well as the
rest
of it in your stomach so if you condense
that food and make it very very small
and all you're getting is those very
calorically dense oils along with
processed sugars or whatever else you're
eating with it
you're not going to be able to
understand as well when your body is
ready to stop eating because it won't
fill up as easily
as when you're eating whole plant foods
that have the water and fiber
intact because the water and fiber
singles to your stomach
that it's getting full and it's time to
stop eating so that's one reason why so
many people struggle with
learning when to stop eating and not to
eat too much because
the way that processed foods are
designed have a ton of
oils and processed sugars with them
along with everything else
making it calorically dense and hard for
your body to truly understand
what's natural for us to stop eating
this doesn't mean never eat oil or
processed sugar and some people may do
fine with a little bit of extra virgin
olive oil
but it's important and helpful to
understand the difference between
isolated foods and whole foods
when ensuring what should be your
dominant calorie source most diets
require some form of calorie restriction
because if you're not eating a
predominantly or exclusively plant-based
diet it becomes very easy to
eat too many calories and to not know
when to stop eating and to not feel
satisfied
by eating whole plant foods you're also
getting more nutrients in
because you're eating everything with
all of their stuff intact like the
vitamins and minerals
also another thing that happens with
restrictive diets is that you teach your
body often to be less hungry
which is not good long term and that
affects your metabolism which is so
hugely important for your health the
next tip is to eat enough calories and
don't skip breakfast
this is one of the most important tips
that i can give along how to thrive on a
plant-based diet especially if you're
new to eating this way
because plant foods are lower in
calories than animal-based and processed
foods so you get to eat more bites of
food to become satisfied and this can
take some getting used to
you should be eating when you're hungry
and stopping when you're full
unlike all the other ways of eating that
we're taught our whole life which is
told to
completely confuse our natural signals
and intuition on when to eat
it is time to start eating when you're
hungry and stopping when you're full
this is extremely satisfying for you and
we'll be adding more nutrients into your
body because the more bites of food you
eat the more nutrition you're getting
into your body especially from whole
plant foods
and don't skip breakfast skipping
breakfast is not going to help your
metabolism long term you need to be
eating when you wake up
and don't wait so long no need to just
wait hours and hours upon before you
start your breakfast
the second tip or the next tip that's
not second i'm on like the fourth one is
to eat a wide variety of whole plant
foods gut health is super important and
one of the most important factors
of having a healthy gut is to eat a wide
variety of whole plant foods don't be
afraid
to check out new vegetables and fruits
at the grocery
store and get experimenting in the
kitchen
eat real plant foods whole not processed
the next tip is to learn how to read
ingredient labels
this is hugely important and once you
learn what exact ingredients are in your
food you'll soon and quickly realize
that
a lot of foods that you once thought
were healthy were actually not that
healthy
if it has a really long ingredients list
it's probably not a health food if it
has ingredients on there that you have a
hard time pronouncing or you don't
recognize
it's probably not a health food well it
doesn't mean that you should never be
eating foods that are not perfectly
healthy like i said before i think this
is a very important point which is
actually my last point
in the whole podcast is to have balance
and to learn about food freedom and not
living stressfully because
eating stressfully and living a
stress-filled life where it's like
centered and obsessed around your food
is definitely damaging and not going to
be adding to your health so balance is
super important
but when you learn how to read
ingredient labels and
figure out and decipher which foods that
do have some ingredients that are like
health promoting versus ones that
are not going to be health enhancing
this is going to help you long term when
you're making decisions
and deciding what foods to bring into
your home the next tip is don't avoid
fruit
fruit is one of the most perfect human
foods like i said earlier it looks
tastes and smells amazing in its natural
state
the body runs on glucose and is the
preferred source of fuel for our bodies
the brain runs on glucose
so if you deprive your body of foods
filled with fruits and tubers
you're gonna have a harder time having
great energy and also feeling as
satisfied because if you're getting a
sweet tooth
and you're craving sweets at the end of
the day you're likely not eating enough
fresh fruit
or tubers so definitely eat plenty of
the fresh fruits
and tubers as well the next one is
greens definitely get your greens in
greens i think are one of the most
important aspects of
thriving long term on a plant-based diet
i love my kale
i love collard greens i love butter
lettuce and light
tender greens as well all of those
greens have wonderful amounts of folate
and
iron and antioxidants and the bone
health superstar vitamin k
and also i think it's really important
to chew your food really well
if you're having trouble digesting lots
of greens because
some people think that greens aren't
really a human food and some people
think that greens don't digest well for
us
when really the problem isn't really the
greens most the time the problem
is are you chewing your food well and
eating mindfully and not shoveling in
your food
we live in a society now where
everything is so fast-paced and you just
want to shovel your food in
or watch something mindlessly while
you're eating
and it can be really really helpful to
just chew your food well something so
simple as chewing your greens taking
your time with it and being mindful with
your food and if you're new to eating
fresh fruits and vegetables in abundance
and you have a sensitive gut
you are the one who needs this
information most definitely read
five refueled by dr will bolsoewitz it's
an amazing read
you have to fix the gut to reap the
benefits of better health
and to fix the gut you need fiber and
diversity of plants
many people find it helpful to slowly
incorporate and adding more and more
plant foods into their diet
rather than doing it all at once to help
their
body and their digestive system adjust
their digestion system will heal over
time
and you'll be stronger your gut will
become stronger and it depends on what
you feed it
so if all of a sudden one day you eat a
massive salad that you're not used to
eating and you know we don't eat greens
you might feel some sensitivity but if
over time
you heal your guts through proper
guidance with medical
experts and with your practitioner and
also from experts like dr wilbolsowitz
people like that who really have helped
so many people
you will be in good hands and you can
take the time to heal by slowly
incorporating those foods
starchy vegetables eat all the sweet
potatoes the okinawans ate over
60 of their calories from sweet potatoes
it is a wonderful
health enhancing and super satisfying
plant food that's rich in calories i
highly recommend
putting sweet potatoes or even squashes
and regular golden potatoes
on your plate every single day i love my
sweet potatoes
also beans and whole grains definitely
get those in as a staple part of your
diet beans and tofu are a great source
of protein and whole grains are
calorically dense and nutritious
high consumption of beans and whole
grains and of course fruits and
vegetables is associated with better
overall health
and about 65 percent of the calories
from the blue zone diets come from whole
grains beans
and tubers eating whole grains and
increasing that consumption
is associated with lowering your risk of
disease in general
many kinds of diseases but let's
specifically talk about optimizing your
bioavailability you can get more
nutrition out of your beans and legumes
if you soak them overnight
they start to pre-digest the sugars and
it has optimal protein as well that way
this also applies to grains and nuts as
well
pour them into your soups but before you
do that rinse them
drain off the soaking liquid rinse it a
few times and
add it to your soups and then all those
minerals go into the wonderful
vegetable soups that you're eating as
well and if you're in
a reproductive age especially you want
to be
interested and looking to your iron
absorption and increasing that as well
so
vitamin c increases iron absorption add
lemon juice to your greens or your
broccoli to increase that iron
absorption for you
also cooking garlic and onions with your
foods helps absorption of zinc better
so saute the garlic and onions with your
greens is definitely going to help with
that
also iodine iodine is hugely important
for
thyroid health so definitely get that
iodine in
i love sea vegetables especially doles
it's my favorite way to
enjoy sea vegetables it's my favorite
sea vegetable out there and i like to
add it to my salads a few times a week i
also give it to the kids a few times a
week in their salads
and lastly just general mineral focus is
very helpful
get coconut waters if you can if you
have access to it also
aloe vera and all of the nutrient dense
greens that we talked about
berries greens of course beans and
starchy vegetables like sweet potatoes
and squashes
next let's talk about healthy fats which
are great i personally feel my best
eating healthy fats in moderation there
really are only a few plant foods that
are rich in fat which is avocado
coconuts and nuts and seeds and if
you're eating a wide variety of whole
plant foods
including fruits and vegetables whole
grains and legumes
then healthy fats becomes a part of that
but it's not the dominant part of it
because you're eating such a wide
variety
it is very easy though to overdo it on
the nut butters and i think this is an
important point
because in nature we really wouldn't be
eating so many nuts they're actually
very hard for us to open
and if we were to be doing it naturally
we'd be only eating a few or a handful
of them
not be getting these large quantities in
bulk bins or huge scoopfuls of nut
butters
we totally as a family do enjoy nut
butters and let me just make that clear
but i do think it's important to not
overdo it and just to be mindful of that
so out of all these plant foods that
we've talked about whole plant foods
legumes beans fresh fruits and
vegetables and healthy
fats like avocados and seeds i love the
hemp seeds hemp seeds are a wonderful
seed to add to your diet we love adding
them to our smoothies or sprinkling on
salads
all of these foods should be the
predominant part of our diet that we're
eating in
abundance but the last tip that i have
is balance
let me be clear this doesn't mean that
you should never be eating something
that isn't like totally health enhancing
the importance is the majority of what
you're eating so for us
as a family that means everything or
pretty much mostly everything we're
bringing into our home is whole plant
foods for a while we were getting lazy
with like making our own hummus we were
feeling really busy with just having our
fourth child
having a newborn and three older kids
and we were just buying that big time
hummus
at the big box grocery store and then
once we
got to a place where we were filling a
little bit more with our head on our
shoulders a little bit less crazy in
life we're like all right
we're ready to start making our own
hummus again we don't need to be buying
this hummus that has
like processed oils in it and things
that aren't necessarily health enhancing
and we feel really good about that
balance of there's gonna be certain
times when it's not perfect
but for the most part the majority of
what we're eating is fresh fruits and
vegetables
whole plant foods and really your health
lies in
the majority of what you're eating so
it's not that five to ten percent
of foods that you're eating is where
your health lies what you decide to do
with that five to ten percent is really
up to you but i personally choose to eat
totally plant-based vegan because i
don't want to support the suffering of
animals and i want to cause the least
amount of suffering that i can
and also because the science is very
clear that animal foods have a
way higher footprint on the planet and
eating plant-based significantly lowers
your footprint
on the planet that is hugely important
to me as well so it's far more than just
the one reason i'm eating for my health
which makes it an easy choice for me to
eat totally vegan all right that is
about everything i want to cover today i
really hope you enjoyed this episode and
i'm very excited for part two
which i'm going to be covering more
specifically on meal planning
and how to center foods and what to
center the food around on your plate
and also i'll be talking more about the
blue zones and diving more into that and
talking about their longevity and health
and
other ways that it helps them to be the
longest living cultures other than just
the foods that they eat
so i can't wait for that and thank you
so much for joining i will see you next
episode
you